I do think that behavior has improved,
uh,
at least on the margin,
if not more.
So we haven't seen,
you know,
it's funny for all of the,
uh,
financial destruction in the markets
that have taken place.
You know,
this,
this has been a period where we had not
seen people,
uh,
get,
get taken away in handcuffs,
uh,
whether it be on Wall Street or
elsewhere.
You know,
occasionally you hear about an insider
trading ring or you know,
a one off,
usually some mom and pop in
Czechoslovakia that seemed to get,
you know,
taken out,
taken away,
but you haven't heard of a,
of big time CEO's and a lot of trouble.
And,
and I do think that one of the,
one of the things that was going on
during the Enron period and why
prosecutors were as harsh as they were,
and I know a lot of people thought they
were too harsh,
um,
was that they were really thinking about
the deterrence factor.
And at least so far now we talked about
short memories on Wall Street,
at least so far it's working.
Um,
as I said before,
everything comes in cycles.
And I can't imagine we won't do this all
again anyway.